if I went to you five years ago and said
that in five years
you would have a series of events the
biggest and worst rights we we've seen
in this country in 50 years far left
extremists would tear down the
barricades of the White House set fire
to a guard post and the church across
the street the president would be forced
into a emergency bunker into an
emergency bunker underneath then uh
later on
several a hundred Trump supporters would
breach the capital during the accounting
of electoral college which would result
in federal agents raiding the homes of
people across the country even innocent
people having their homes raided by feds
and ultimately Donald Trump would not
only be indicted in multiple
jurisdictions but the Democrat doj
would be preparing indictments against
his lawyers and Democrats at the state
level would have indicted his lawyers
if I were to tell you all that you tell
me I was crazy I know for a fact because
when I said in 2018 that what we are
seeing on the ground will eventually
find its way to the federal government I
was I was told that I was crazy